AMIT CHAUDHRY: We are seeing
more and more enterprises
embracing a hybrid
and now increasingly
multi-cloud strategy
for their applications.
Made on prem and cloud, or
even deploying components
between multiple cloud
renders, developer
needs tools and agility to
embrace hybrid environments,
so they can handle
real-time scale that's
available across the world.
DataStax is a master list,
active everywhere database
built on Apache Cassandra and
designed for Hybrid Cloud.
DSE Active Everywhere
architecture
enables customers to build a
consistent operational data
layer across on premise,
hybrid cloud, and multi-cloud,
thereby eliminating data
silos and accelerating
hybrid multi-cloud deployments.
DataStax Enterprise
is a foundation
for building highly distributed
real-time applications that
need infinite
scalability, no downtime,
and global availability
in any cloud.
And now, with Google
Cloud, DataStax
can provide more flexible ways
to create seamless enterprise
clusters across
different regions using
VMs and Kubernetes deployments.
Active Everywhere capability
of DataStax Enterprise,
supported with Google's
global network,
enables real-time
applications across the globe.
But the power of Google Cloud
for DSE doesn't stop at VMs
and deployments.
It's also about security
at all layers of the cloud.
It's also about manageability.
Google Cloud
provides the leading
managed production-ready
environment for containers.
And it's also about
the network backbone
that Google has of
thousands of miles of fiber
optic cable that make
multi-region data stack
deployment much easier
than other clouds.
With GKE on premise,
our customers
get the Google Kubernetes
Engine experience directly
in their data center.
GKE is production-ready
and reliable for DSE
to deploy either on
premise or in GCP,
therefore providing customers
a very strong and efficient
hybrid cloud solution,
something that
enhances the DataStax
hybrid storing
that customers need today.
Now, like most
companies, DataStax
wants to find the
most customers that we
can help with their offering.
And for this, we can
turn to GCP Marketplace.
This marketplace
allows developers
to find the solutions
for their projects
with AI-powered recommendations,
in-product marketplace windows,
and available free trials.
With just a few clicks, you
can get DataStax Enterprise
deployed quickly
to your project,
trusting that the
image has been verified
against vulnerabilities and
optimized to run on GCP.
Check out the links
in the description
below for more
information, and don't
hesitate to reach out to us with
any questions you might have.
Thanks for watching.